адже вона на такі суд у культур не шляхів
від міжнародний кінофестиваль берлінале
місяць і томи українську російську
конфлікту на тиждень cool і особливих труднощів
йдуть на кінопокази
не мати кота європейської кіноакадемії
спина занести інтернешнл ваш штурвала
акцію на пит ринку за звуженого до 20
річкового у явно не професора олега
Сєнцова
тасс я чому нічого на руб
людей просто забудуть там і так вашу його
знову і знову говорить про процес смислів
так силва знаєте ще його необхідний дзвенить
і хто раніше всерйоз подівся але те
ще вибачити ходорковського ніхто 3-го
приклад то ти у вас похмурої швидкості до
подібних випадки аджі на ютьюбі лише
безнадійних може і зради confide бочки
видос з рада учасники акції та член
української довготи та на берлінале
режисер наріманий аліїв родом з криму я
кивала їх самців на кінофестиваль вин
пронесли teens in this вс
кримськотатарської але за прикладати і їх
гостей у цьому далеко на те далеко я
піду з тобою я прийду з тобою обоє
booster
зустрічку знімала вже зараз купувати та
цієї історії історія кримську татарську
родену розпродують про вибачення та цінувати
як близьких людей так і рідної землі це
було собі таке ж було прощання з
кримом з будинку в q&a line вона за кермом
він відсік виродки частини вікна мірі я
намахався заробляєш загальну сізо по
металу себе в тому криму
we кому я живу будь-які вже досягла 6
українське кіно стригти про які права злі
на берлінале
нову вови провернулася сама ti2
таки раз повідають проукраїнську
російський конфлікт крем без tb наримана
алієва з маріуполе man to suck води rave
години прожити а українці
у прифронтовому маріуполі